voilà eh bien écoutez la tension est
toujours extrêmement tendue ici
boulevard voltaire et je suis justement
avec eric coquerel des buts est de la
france
insoumise un symbole si vous voulez ce
défilé du 1er mai pour tous les
syndicats pour tous les français
finalement c'est symbole est un peu
écorché écornée aujourd'hui par ces à
passer toujours tenir d'abord c'est le
monde il ya beaucoup beaucoup de monde
et j'ai pas envie qu'on se confondent
compte commandes que joueur avec la
police parce que c'est à ça que ça sert
aussi la gestion du maintien de l'ordre
depuis des années dans ce pays et
notamment avec les cautionnements il ya
beaucoup de monde parce qu'il ya il ya
quelque chose dans ce pays en terme
social qui est des plus supporter ça
vient l'idée de faire payer la crise aux
travailleurs
avec la réforme des retraites la réponse
de la question chômage le fait qu'il ya
des licenciements dans des entreprises
qui touchent des bénéfices et qui font
des profits et qui touche de l'es2 les
publics de l'état
tout ça c'est insupportable c'est pour
ça que je crois que c'est un des plus
gros 1er mai depuis longtemps - auquel
on assiste
oui justement cette mobilisation aussi
elle et elle témoigne si vous venez d'un
réveil social d'un printemps social
effectivement puisque l'année dernière
il n'y a pas eu des filets à cause de la
crise duco vide et on a l'impression que
cette crise sanitaire a mis de côté
toutes les questions sociales et toutes
ces réformes sociales c'est absolument
ça c'est à dire qu'au fait ces crises
sanitaires à c'est pas facile de se
mobiliser pour une crise sanitaire mais
n'empêche il ya des mobilisations
notamment dans les entreprises où il ya
des plans sociaux aujourd'hui organisé
et c'est tout ce monde-là qui se
retrouvent dans la rue
moi je pense qu'on peut avoir un
printemps social important tout cas je
le souhaite
bon si le goût
moment arrête aussi de d'utiliser la
manière d'un maintien de l'ordre qui
souvent est là aussi pour créer des
incidents et comparses ne parle pas
d'autre chose
voilà ce que je veux retenir aujourd'hui
c'est car beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde pour ce 1er mai dans la rue et
pour vous en tant qu'élu politique
justement c'était important d'être là
dans la rue avec avec les manifestants
les français les organisations
syndicales
ouais parce que le 1er mai c'est la fête
du droit des travailleurs et non pas du
travail comme des fois je l'entends et
j'en ai le chef a dû rater beaucoup de
fuites chez chez depuis que j'ai engagé
politiquement donc aujourd'hui spéciale
puis lens était important de se
retrouver ici puisque l'an dernier comme
vous l'avez dit il n'y avait pas eu de
1er mai merci beaucoup monsieur kokal
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes a débuté vers 308
voilà en tout cas on est toujours bloqué
ici boulevard voltaire à l'est les
affrontements se multiplient entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre des
jets de projectiles de mobilier urbain
qui sont qui sont jetés vers les forces
de l'ordre et forces de l'ordre
répondent par des gaz lacrymogènes
et encore une fois le cortège se
dérouler d'une manière extrêmement calme
et tout a dégénéré d'un coup un
important dispositif de sécurité on en
parlait tout à l'heure a été mise en
place environ 5000 policiers ont encadré
ce cortège ça n'a pas empêché les
débordements voilà vous l'envoie vous
l'entendez encore des pétards et qui
explosent autour de autour de nous et
ces affrontements qui se multiplient si
vous voulez empêche le cortège d'avancer
vers son point final vers sa destination
finale
la place de la nation pour ce défilé du
1er mai merci david 1